it's easy to become numb the media bias
these days so the ingram angle
we're keeping track of the worst
offenders of the week and we have some
doozies joining me now
jeffrey lord former cnn commentator
contributing editor
of the american spectator and corey
lewandowski former trump advisor
and maga action chairman all right panel
great to see both of you
uh this week was a special one i think
for the media
because they have their hands on a few
new
first-hand accounts three separate trump
books
being the scrupulous journalists that
they are they probe for
inconsistencies watch
how i've waited for this moment
congratulations this book is just
spectacular
creative reading here okay um dramatic i
should say thanks for writing the book
jeffrey i seem to remember michael
wolff's last book being riddled with
lies and
there you have another you know wolf
blitzer thanking him for
you know the new tome well thank you
thank you for doing
thank you for trashing trump it's really
you know laura once upon a time uh i
remember and i'm sure you do that books
about presidents
by people who had been around them or
interviewed people who've been around
them
they were either very objective
fact-driven or
they lionized them i think of jfk good
lord even jimmy carter
not to mention barack obama the american
people
know that there are people out there who
want to do nothing but trash donald
trump
for bucks and that's what these books
are about they're not about history
they're about trashing him for bucks and
sad to say
they get it from mainstream media types
who egg them on
now one of the books claims that general
mark milley
said something about trump's supporters
while preparing for biden's inauguration
watch
millie says to a group of senior
advisors at this
exercise quote here's the deal guys
these guys are nazis they're boogaloo
boys they're proud boys
these are the same people we fought in
world war
ii we're going to put a ring of steel
around this city and the nazis aren't
getting in and by that he was referring
to trump supporters corey
we're kind of used to hearing this stuff
from the far left on college campuses
blm those kinds of things but chairman
of the joint chiefs
uh talking about you know a lot of
people who just
went to support the president didn't
even go into the capitol
he obviously if this is what he said he
gave it to them this is from him
your reaction or if this is what he said
he is unfit to serve as the highest
ranking military officer in our country
but what we have seen time and again
from these reporters is that they have
been quote
manipulated by the press uh and by the
stories and that was the case with the
steele dossier the press was manipulated
we saw that during the supposed tear gas
use in lafayette park that donald trump
ordered only to come to find out
that was never the case we heard the
reporters tell us that on january 6 a
police officer was beaten to death
with a fire extinguisher to his brain
and that's what killed him
of course that was also untrue there
have been time and time again
and and one an additional example is
when president trump was having a
conversation with the secretary of state
of georgia
where he said go find the votes and many
outlets
independently verify that until the
audio of course was actually released
and all of them were wrong so look if
general milley said that
then i don't think he has the right to
serve in that capacity but i
always call in to question these
reporters who have their own agenda
which is to disparage donald trump every
day that they can
i think he i i mean i have no doubt that
he said that
i mean to me everything that he said
since about white rage and all
i i think he absolutely said it and i
agree with you he should be removed
immediately from his position because he
should just go work for msnbc or
something jeff i want to hear
how millie described um i want everyone
to hear this how he described the
violent riots that
we all witnessed last year last summer
that caused millions of dollars worth of
damage and a lot of lives ended up
getting lost watch
one of the the most striking scenes for
the book for me is
is trump trying to put troops into u.s
cities
and and merely having to point to the
portrait of lincoln
and say that he had an insurrection mr
president what we have
is a civil rights protest
jeff what's amazing here is that millie
always comes across
as the the hero of the scene that's a
tell-tale sign he's the one who gave
them all this information
but the journalists don't seem to be
probing they seem to be
just repeating without question
that's right you know somewhere dr
martin luther king is just shaking his
head
for journalists to sit back and accept
the description of what happened last
summer as civil rights protest
is an insult to all of those people who
peacefully demonstrated for civil rights
in the 1960s
and the media just swallows this and
takes it
uh i i mean this is really really
disgraceful i mean the general
frankly i think should be removed you
should not be sitting there
but the media what are they thinking
what what they're thinking is they're
putting their leftist politics
before common sense now one of the books
including describing those riots was
peaceful it was crazy
yeah well one of the books um includes
another
interaction and this one cory was
between
liz cheney and jim jordan that happened
on january 6th
millie asks her on the phone how are you
doing
and cheney says quote that effing guy
jim jordan that son of while these
maniacs
are going through the place i'm standing
in the aisle
and he said we need to get the ladies
away from the
aisle let me help you i smacked his hand
away and told him
get away from me you effing
did this corey your reaction to this
claim
you know laura anybody who's ever had a
conversation with liz cheney knows that
that's exactly what happened she has a
prolific truck driver mouth
and the fact that you know she used that
language on the house floor doesn't
surprise me
what it really shows though is that liz
cheney's
disdain for donald trump and the
supporters of donald trump
has been has been paramount for years
you know donald trump destroyed
uh her father's legacy donald trump want
to take out our troops
and she want to keep our troops fighting
for other nations
in perpetuity and so liz cheney has
always disdained donald
trump she lost her leadership position
in the house she's going to lose her
re-election effort
in wyoming but anybody who knows liz
cheney knows that this is the way she
talks on a regular basis
well i think i have no doubt that any of
this was said by any of these characters
and it was all given to the media to try
to burnish their own legacies this is
what happens in all these books
you know the rats are leaving leaving
the titanic of the democrat party or at
least they're trying to get off the ship
without drowning jeff and corey thanks
for being with us tonight
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else